il réclame est une évaluation en
contrôle continu ce sera en fin de
compte en examen final en présentiel
pour les étudiants en bts lors d'un
point presse le 22 avril dernier le
ministre de l'éducation nationale a
tranché après le nouvel les examens sont
romands seraient en présence mais avec
des conditions sanitaires strictes
il en va de même aussi pour les
étudiants de bts c'est un sujet dont
j'ai été beaucoup saisie je voudrais
m'adresser la veille tout
particulièrement puisque j'ai bien
compris qu'il y avait parfois un malaise
pour certains d'entre eux qu'ils se
sentent même parfois mal préparé du fait
des circonstances je voudrais dire donc
quelques éléments sur ce point le
premier c'est que bien entendu nous
sommes capables de prendre en
considération les situations
particulières
chaque bds est un cas particulier
frédéric vidal appui annoncé la semaine
dernière que nous faisions une session
de rattrapage
cela signifie donc que les épreuves de
bts prévu au mois de mai auront lieu
mais que pour ceux qui ne pourraient pas
y aller parce qu'ils seraient malades ou
qui échoueraient à cette épreuve il aura
une session de rattrapage au début du
mois de juillet cette session de
rattrapage consistera en euros et ses
oraux pourront être préparés
spécifiquement en mai et juin
nous dégageons les moyens
supplémentaires pour qu'il y ait un
impact compagne mans personnalisé de
chaque élève
jean michel blanquer elle a assuré il
s'agit pour l'exécutif de garantie à la
valeur
et d'offrir aux étudiants le meilleur
entraînement pour les examens à venir
mais certains ne l'entendent pas de
cette oreille ce sera donc à la justice
de trancher le 23 avril un millier
d'étudiants et plusieurs associations
ont décidé de porter plainte contre le
ministre de l'éducation nationale et la
ministre de l'enseignement supérieur
leur avocat l'a annoncé dans un
communiqué 400 personnes dans une même
salle
pendant que les collèges lycées et
établissements de l'enseignement
supérieur sont fermés en raison de la
situation sanitaire
cela est plein compréhensible et expose
ses jeunes non seulement un risque de
contamination par le kobe 19 mais aussi
à des risques psychologiques
parmi les autres actions intentées en
recours en référé a été déposé auprès du
conseil d'état
l'avocat qui a aussi précisé qu'une
plainte avait été déposée devant la cour
de justice de la république contre les
deux ministres pour je cite mise en
danger de la vie d'autrui
objectif faire annuler les examens en
présentiel et mettre les ministres
devant leurs responsabilités nous dit le
communiqué jean michel blanquer air
était l'invité du grand jury sur lci ce
dimanche réponse les plaintes donc pas
lieu d'être a affirmé le ministre de
l'éducation nationale reste à savoir si
cet avis sera partagée par les
magistrats